all right let's get into audience
questions for the week david shouldn't
joe biden be bragging about the stock
market the way trump did i don't mean
because joe biden is actually
responsible for the stock market
but because trump seemed to do well when
he bragged about it
i i like the way that this question is
asked because
it's not being asked as a question of
whether joe biden deserves credit i mean
as we've talked about before
to some degree the sort of economic
circumstances uh over which a president
has
some influence impact the stock market
but the stock market performance alone
is often used kind of as a political
football and donald trump
certainly regularly would talk about how
great the stock market is doing when it
was up
not when it was down and many of his
followers fell for it
it's really a question of whether
politically it would be advantageous for
joe biden to do it
i think that it's not clear that it
would because
joe biden's base is so different than
donald trump's base
donald trump's base was
disproportionately made up of people who
were never involved in politics before
or who were and they fell for republican
nonsense
so they were like the perfect marks for
just hearing from trump
about the stock market and the joe biden
base
is different and it doesn't strike me as
something that would
be so obviously beneficial
for joe biden to brag about the stock
market in the same way that donald trump
did now
that being said just because you don't
have
the sort of sycophantic cult of
personality cheerleaders on the left
that you had on the right around donald
trump doesn't mean joe biden shouldn't
talk about the stock market in the
context
of talking about how we're doing so
certainly joe biden should be saying
we're vaccinating more than 3 million a
day
are down 77 percent cases are down
roughly the same percentage
uh unemployment is down we are seeing
job creation
stock market is at record highs on and
up right so it's a package
overall but if the question is should
joe biden
start tweeting about the stock market
from a golf course the way
you know the caricature of what donald
trump was doing i don't think it's
it's what joe biden should be doing one
other aspect to why it's important
for biden to talk about the stock market
numbers
is that you do want to try at least
to get the media to
put out messages that are advantageous
to you
any president would try to do this and
rather than just leaving it to corporate
media to figure out oh the stock market
is doing well and joe biden's president
and we were told that it was going to be
a disaster by trump if joe biden were
president
why not again this this is sort of like
communications in pr
feed the story to the media in in some
sense
one one other aspect of this
when donald trump insisted during the
campaign
that if joe biden wins your 401ks will
be worth nothing
the economy will collapse unemployment
will explode
coveted death will explode suicides will
explode you won't have windows and
buildings you won't have indoor heating
you won't have indoor cooling you'll
have to flush your toilet 10 to 15 times
you'll have to run your dishwasher two
or three times to get your dishes clean
we knew all that stuff was crazy but in
particular now
joe biden talking about what the stock
market is doing
might be a good way to get media outlets
to put more republicans on the spot
and say you agreed with trump during the
campaign that if joe
biden were president this would happen
to the market the markets at record
highs what say you
they would almost certainly retreat to
something like well joe biden has
inflated the stock market by
quote printing money through stimulus
and he wants to do infrastructure
but they'll be on the ropes and they
will have a defense it'll be a really
stupid defense so the
the position joe biden should take is
take
credit for turning things around
and talk about the stock market as one
of many
indicators as to how things are
continuing to improve
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently checked
out the book podcast marketing strategy
by daniel rolls and kieran rogers and
so useful so particularly applicable to
what i'm doing
really recommend it blinkist has books
on politics philosophy science they have
27 different non-fiction categories and
a subscription is only about eight bucks
a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video